Sophia nices choreographer and dramat
age Germany Sophia is a white woman in
her 30s who identifies as disabled she
has short blonde hair and is wearing a
white cotton top and colorful jeans she
is interviewed in front of a large
mirror and her interview is presented
alongside video clips of Productions on
which Sophia has worked and workshops
she has taken part in
the Productions are invisible by Jess
Curtis gravity and non-visual palpable
dance lab by swissimus Clark
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my nickname is fear
[Music]
um which is the acronym for future is
accessible
[Music]
since I work more and more as a
dramaturk I would describe that work
more as
I'm double checking geometry G's
in terms of is this piece
also great for visually impaired and
blind audience members not just
accessible great
[Music]
I think I've never made a piece that was
specifically only for a blind obviously
impaired people
but what I do or achieve are projects
that I accept to collaborate are
projects that have in mind that also In
Their audience
visually impaired and blind people are
with their tried to find Solutions of
like how is how is dancing together if
it's not about being visual with each
other and for me it was also then really
interesting to explore dance when you
actually don't need
um an audio description because the
audio description sometimes
it feels like it's forcing me to see
which I'd rarely do but then hearing all
the descriptions of the visuals is kind
of I experienced the performance plus I
have to hear all the visual stuff that's
happening it's kind of like forcing this
way of perceiving on to me I would
rather having the freedom to explore it
myself
foreign
[Music]
art I noticed it's not accessible I have
to and I had to
fight all the time to have access I had
to become an activist it was not really
by choice even if I don't talk about
disability this is so rare that we see
disabled people in the scene
and just with my presence it's already
activist
foreign
[Music]